[MUSIC PLAYING]
CRISTIN FRODELLA: I'm very
excited to welcome back
one of those incredible
women, Anjali Kumar.
So many of you may
remember Anjali as one
of our fearless lawyers,
a senior counsel who
worked on projects from
Google X to YouTube.
But many more of you
may remember Anjali
for hosting the At
Google speaker series,
bringing in incredible chefs
like Anthony Bourdain, Jacques
Pepin, Marcus Samuelsson.
I hope you got some
really good secret recipes
from all these folks.
ANJALI KUMAR: I got a lot of
really great reservations,
I will tell you.
I still milk that.
Yeah.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Nice.
And to entertainers
like Questlove,
who you might remember from her
series "Lunchtime at Google--"
ANJALI KUMAR:
Short-lived, but so fun.
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
--which was delightful.
Anjali, like most of us, knows
that most people's hearts live
in their stomach,
and so you're always
having people who can
talk to us about food.
So after leaving
Google, Anjali went
to be Founding General
Counsel and Founding
Head of Social Innovation
at Warby Parker,
and most recently was the Chief
People Officer at Cheddar.
And throughout these jobs,
Anjali was also pretty busy
starting a family with
her beloved husband, Atul.
In 2010, she had
a daughter, Zia,
and it was right around
then that she started
to think about religion.
And as a new mom myself, I
can totally relate to the fact
that there's nothing like
having a baby to make
you peek your head up
around out of your bubble
and say, how do I explain
the mysteries of life?
So Anjali's here
today to tell us
a little bit about how she
turned over every rock in what
seemed like every corner
of the world's religions
and spiritual groups and sects
in her incredibly delightful
book, "Stalking God.
So without further
ado, please help
me give a warm welcome
back to Anjali Kumar.
ANJALI KUMAR: Thank you.
Thank you so much for having me.
It is such a thrill to be here.
And to actually not know
everybody in the audience
means that more
Googlers showed up
than just my team,
which is so meaningful.
Thank you.
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
So Anjali, tell
us a little bit about yourself.
Like what was life like
growing up for you?
Where'd you grow up?
How did you kind of
get to this place
where you were asking
all these questions?
ANJALI KUMAR: Sure.
So I was born in
Brooklyn, actually,
but raised outside of Chicago.
Go Brooklyn.
Woo-hoo for Brooklyn.
And raised outside of
Chicago by Indian parents.
Jain is my religion,
so it's sort
of a small, very minority
religion, at least outside
of India, but raised
culturally Hindu, and also went
to Catholic school.
You might get a sense of why
I wrote this book when you
start hearing things like that.
There are a lot of religion and
a lot of traditions around me.
And for me, it was
really cultural,
and it was just something that I
never really thought much about
or questioned because
it was so seamlessly
interwoven into our lives and
I just never felt the need
to ask the big questions.
And as you said, it was when my
daughter, Zia, was born, which
happened when I was at Google.
Not physically at Google, but--
oh.
Hold on.
We're having a mic issue.
Oh, keep going.
OK so it was while I
was employed at Google.
I had my daughter Zia
about eight years ago,
almost nine years ago.
And it was in a
conversation with my dad
when he said to me soon
after she was born,
he was like oh, you should
take her to the temple.
There's a Jain
temple out in Queens
and you should take her there
to show her what we believe.
And I was like,
what do we believe?
I was like, huh.
That's a really
interesting question.
I was like, what do we believe?
Wait, did I miss something?
Because I was into
the traditions
and I wanted to do all the
right things and like, you know,
check off all the traditional
boxes, but I was like,
I don't really know
what I believe,
and I just had never
thought about it.
So I decided to start
researching because I realized
at some point, there would
be this set of questions
that my daughter would
inevitably ask me.
Like what happens when you die?
Is there a god?
How do you find happiness?
What's the meaning of life?
Things that I could not
Google an answer to.
Literally that was the
start of the journey.
And so I started doing
research and I was like, well
what do I really believe?
And maybe I'll go
see this healer
and go do this other thing.
And it started as
a very quiet thing
because I worked at
Google and I was like,
everyone's going to
think I'm bananas.
And I worked at Google
in the legal department,
so the last thing you
want is your lawyer
going off and doing
all this crazy stuff.
But then as I started telling
people, and especially
colleagues at
Google, they really
surprised me because
they started being like,
oh, have you checked
out this thing?
And like, I know this healer
downtown or I saw this shaman
or I've tried
ayahuasca or whatever.
And I was like, what?
I was like, everybody's doing
this stuff except for me?
So like I'm the only one
who hasn't been searching,
and that's what started
the whole thing.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: While
I was thinking about
like what can I
talk with you about,
I was looking at emails
that we had exchanged,
and there is one titled Amma.
And you and I are both
friends with Gopi, who--
ANJALI KUMAR: Googler
extraordinaire [INAUDIBLE]..
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Yes.
If you guys don't
know Gopi, you should,
but he started
the Yoglers group,
and he teaches yoga
out in California
amongst the many
other things that he
does including being Googler.
And he turned a lot
of us on to Amma.
who is sort of
the hugging saint.
And I know you wrote
about Amma in your book.
Can you tell us a
little bit about her?
ANJALI KUMAR: Sure.
She's actually my
opening chapter,
and it was through a
conversation with Gopi
where he was like, oh, I
follow this woman, Amma.
She goes around the world
literally hugging people.
That's her job.
That's what she does.
It sounds like kind
of a weird job,
but she makes a lot
of money doing this.
And so she goes around
the world giving hugs.
And she was coming just
to midtown Manhattan
and it was July 4th
weekend many summers ago,
so I was like, all right,
I'm going to go check it out.
And I jump in a
cab and I go there,
and it was so interesting.
It was like lines out the
door, thousands and thousands
of people.
I stood in line for probably
over four hours waiting
for a hug, and then had this
experience of like settling in.
It was like an over-familiar
auntie, you know,
if you've ever experienced that.
You're kind of like, this
is getting uncomfortable.
Like, can you let
go of the grip?
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
She wouldn't let go?
ANJALI KUMAR: She
wouldn't let go,
but then suddenly, you're
like peeled off of her
and like thrown off to the--
just like a puppy,
like just thrown off.
And it was deeply
unsatisfying for me
personally, but so
satisfying to so many people
there who were in tears
having hugs from her
and who are really
deep followers,
and I think that also
helped me sort of go
into all of these experiences
with a really open mind,
being like, you know, just
because it's not right for me,
there might be something
that I can take from it
and then continue on
the journey to find
what really resonates for me.
But then I really
respect the fact
that Gopi and other friends
of mine really believe in her
and really follow
her around the world
and go every summer
to get a hug from her.
I have not gone back, but
there's great food when you go.
And so if you're
not into the hug,
there's amazing vegetarian food
in the basement of the hall.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Nice.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
There's always
something redeeming
in all of these things.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: So
speaking of belief,
your husband is a doctor, right?
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
As a scientist,
what did he think
about all this?
ANJALI KUMAR: He
thinks I'm bananas.
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
What was his response?
ANJALI KUMAR: What do you think?
He is the most patient
man in the universe.
So he is an interventional
cardiologist,
like he is a
Superman of science.
And I think for him, again,
so much of spirituality,
religion has just been cultural
for him so he doesn't really
think about it.
He doesn't waver
around these questions.
He sort of goes through
the motions of religion.
He's Hindu, was raised Hindu,
and I think, if pressed,
would call himself Hindu.
But he definitely--
there were moments
when I was doing the
research where he was like,
you're not going to do
that, like that's crazy.
Or when I would come
back from things,
he was like, oh my word.
Like the chanting, the
tantric sound healing,
I think that definitely
tested our relationship.
But he's got a good
sense of humor,
so he mostly went along with it.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Nice.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
He did not come with
me on anything though.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: None of them?
ANJALI KUMAR: No, just one.
He did the meditation with me.
He learned TM.
He didn't do the
vipassana, but he
did a transcendental
meditation course with me.
But I found out
later from him it
was because I had told him
about all of these athletes that
did it, professional
athletes that he really
respected and admired.
So he was like, oh really?
Like that's kind of cool?
It's like, you're not
a football player.
Like when do you think this
is going to come in handy?
But he was really into like the
mental toughness aspect of it.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Yeah.
I really want to do it
because of David Lynch.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
That's where I learned.
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
I feel like it's
going to let me write
some sort of crazy thing.
ANJALI KUMAR: It's going
to let you write a book.
I'm telling you.
Yeah.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Maybe.
ANJALI KUMAR: I caught
the big fish through that.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: You did?
Nice.
ANJALI KUMAR: For sure.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Which
is a book by David Lynch.
So after you went
to Amma, what was
sort of like your next step?
Like you're like, OK.
I did this here.
I'm in New York City.
This doesn't work for me.
I know you started
traveling around the world.
You mentioned that your
husband didn't go with you,
but I know your sister
went with you to Brazil
to see John of God.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yes.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: And so I
thought the John of God story
was particularly a little crazy.
ANJALI KUMAR: So John of God--
my sister does not
appear in the chapter,
because the narrative
just worked better
without her in it, but
she was there with me.
John of God is a healer.
A medium is what
they consider him,
so there's a lot of
people around the world,
including Oprah,
who really believe
that he can cure
all that ails you,
whether physical,
emotional, spiritual.
And so people will
go down to see him
in this small town in the middle
of Brazil and get healing.
You sort of just
pass in front of him
and you meditate for days
and that kind of thing,
and he scans, I guess, your
auric field and then heals you.
I don't fully know how it
works because it's definitely
out there.
But people really believe in
him and really believe that he--
CRISTIN FRODELLA: But he
does surgery on people.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
That's crazy.
That stuff is-- yeah, he does
surgery without anesthesia.
Sometimes there's
cutting, and he
claims that he cuts because
the people need to see the cut,
like the patient
needs to see the cut,
but not because it's
actually required.
But there are people
who say that they
have been cured of cancer
and a lot of other things
by going to see John of God.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Did
you see any surgeries
while you were there?
ANJALI KUMAR: I saw some cutting
and some eyeball scraping.
It was really out
there, and it ended up
becoming a real anchor
for me in the narrative
of this particular book.
So it's one of
the first chapters
of the book of going down
to seeing him and, you know,
what happens there.
And then when the
conclusion comes,
it sort of ties
the whole thing up
of what I found on this very
long journey because of things
that happened related to him
but not directly from him.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: So
tell me more about that.
What do you mean?
ANJALI KUMAR: Sure.
So when you go to see John of
God, you can also make wishes,
so you go down with
your three intentions.
It's sort of like wishing
through a genie in a bottle.
And what you can also
do is bring photographs
of other people who would like
to be seen by John of God who
can't make the trip,
so you can save them
the airfare down to Brazil, and
he will scan the photographs
and apparently do
distance healing.
So I guess if you believe
that he can heal you
by looking at you, it's
probably not that much of a leap
to think that he could also
heal other people by scanning
a photograph.
So when I was going down, I
started offering to people,
including some
colleagues at Google,
that I could take
their pictures down
and that I could also take their
wishes down if they wanted.
And then I started
telling random people
because I'm super
chatty, and so I
was telling like the
guy at the coffee shop
and like the lady at Whole Foods
and all these other people.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Did you
have like a stack of photos
with you?
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
So I ended up getting
bombarded with e-mails,
like to the point where
it was really crazy.
Like I just-- so
many emails, and I
had to go run and get a
bunch of photos printed
at the local Duane
Reade and whatever.
And so I went down
with all these wishes
and all these photographs.
And it wasn't until I was kind
of researching the entire book
and working on the conclusion
that I went back and actually
read the emails
with a fresh eye.
And I noticed a few things
in common amongst the emails.
And you know, there were
some things that were not
necessarily as interesting,
like people gave me
very specific instructions
on how they could be reached.
It was like, just in
case this shit's real--
oh, sorry.
Just in case this
is real, I want
to make sure my wish is
going to the right person.
So they gave me
like full addresses,
apartment numbers, like
where they could be reached.
And then the other thing--
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
Like Santa Claus.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
It was like don't
let them screw it up.
If this is going
to be real, I want
to make sure the wishes are
coming, like the good stuff is
coming to my house.
The second thing that
I saw in these wishes
is that everybody was
asking for the same things,
and it was health,
happiness, and love,
and it was in that order.
And then the third thing
is that they all ended,
every single email
ended in the same way,
and they all said,
please don't tell anyone.
Which I thought [INAUDIBLE]
I'm telling all of you,
which is nice of me.
I also told a bunch
people at TED.
I did it on the stage and
I wrote it in my book,
so I told everybody,
but I think it's
because it's really important.
It's important for us to know
that we, at the end of the day,
mostly all want the same things.
So at the end of
the day, despite all
of our differences
and all the things
that we might be searching
for that are different,
all the political divides,
the religious divides,
every other philosophical
divide in this divisive time,
that at the end of
the day, we really all
want the same things.
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
It reminds me of one
of the things you talk
about in your book, which
is Burning Man.
So I've been to Burning Man.
And when you go, you
have the opportunity
to write on the wall of the--
ANJALI KUMAR: The temple.
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
--of the temple,
something usually like a
letter to someone who's
passed or wishes
or whatever, and I
found that to be really moving.
Can you tell us a little bit
about your experience there?
I know there's somebody
in the audience
here you went to
Burning Man with.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
I met him at Burning Man.
We didn't even know
each other at Google,
and we were in the same camp.
I feel like everybody at
Google has gone to Burning Man.
Isn't it a job requirement?
There's nodding heads.
So if you can imagine me, as a
lawyer, going into Burning Man,
like a reasonably uptight
person going to Burning Man,
you can just do the math
of what that experience was
like for me.
It was really
uncomfortable at first.
And I went and I was like,
I feel so out of place
and I don't know
what I am doing here
and I don't have clothes to
radically self express myself,
like I had to borrow this
outfit from somebody.
Like I don't--
I worked in tech.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: You
didn't have costumes?
ANJALI KUMAR: No, I
did not have costumes.
I don't have a lot of
feathers in my wardrobe.
You know, like I don't have
stuff to wear at Burning Man.
No one's going to see
me in a bikini top.
Like it's just not happening.
I've had a child, not happening.
So going there was really
out of my comfort zone
to put myself in that situation,
and I ended up loving it
after a couple of days.
Like once I kind
of got in my groove
and got over myself
and got over the dust
and got over the
general lack of--
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Dryness.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah, just
the dryness and the lack
of sanitary conditions
around bathrooms.
Once I got over that,
I really enjoyed it.
And I feel like you
really-- that cliche
of what you need out
of that experience
is truly what you get, and I
think that was true for me.
I got a lot of rest
at Burning Man.
I think I was the only
person who came back
reasonably well-rested,
which also just tells you
what a nerd I am.
Because I was like,
oh, 11 o'clock,
I'm going to go to sleep.
Like I just was like not
the person staying up
until 5:00 in the morning and
like doing drugs in the desert.
Like I was just like, no, I'm
just going to go read a book
and like, you know, sleep
in the healing dome.
Like I was really
taking it easy.
But I engaged with it in a way
that was comfortable for me,
and I think I got out
of it what I needed to.
And the temple, I think, was
a particularly powerful thing
for me as well.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Did
you write something?
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
I left a lot of
wishes for friends.
Again, I think part of the
journey and the way I've
kind of justified
indulging in this journey
was taking people
along with me virtually
or mentally wherever I could.
So going to Burning Man, it's
like, who else has got a wish?
Like, I'll put it in
the temple for you.
And so writing those for
people was a really emotionally
cathartic experience in a way
that I was really surprised by,
like people who are
mourning friends and loved
ones including a
Googler who had died
in the Nepal earthquake, who
you all probably remember,
who is a friend of mine and
a friend of a lot of friends
in common.
And so just being able to bear
witness to that and to kind
of mark that for his
mom and for his friends
was really meaningful.
So I think, again, I got
out of it what I needed to.
And it's my favorite chapter in
the book, so there's also that.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: So
speaking of the book, when
I was reading it, every
night I would sort of
come home and be like, yeah,
I wonder what wacky story
I'm going to hear tonight.
And it's sort of like
hanging out with you
and getting to hear all
of your best stories.
So what do you think of all
of these wacky adventures?
Like what's the craziest
thing that you saw?
ANJALI KUMAR: I would
say the tantric sound
healing was probably one of
the more out their experiences.
My dad read the book when
the galleys came out,
and he was just like,
he couldn't look me
in the eye for a couple of days.
Like he was just like,
what on earth are you up to
and can you go back to Google?
Are they still hiring?
Can you go back?
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Do
you feel comfortable
telling these guys about it?
ANJALI KUMAR: Sure, yeah.
So the experience was--
I actually went after a
Google sales conference,
because we had a sales
conference out in California.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Did you
go with Google salespeople?
ANJALI KUMAR: No, nobody
from Google joined me.
I should have asked people.
I did not invite anyone
on that particular trip.
But a friend of mine
who is a screenwriter
was going to this thing down
in Southern California, right
outside of LA in Santa Barbara,
and she told me about it.
And so I went to meet her
after Google sales conference
because I was already
on the west coast.
So a lot of the things, it
sounds like a very indulgent--
like oh, I'm like privileged
and flying all over the world.
But I really did tack
a lot of the things
that I did onto work travel.
Not just Google work travel,
but just like generally,
because I'm a mom
and I have a budget
and I'm a working person.
And so trying to coordinate
these things into real life
was part of the challenge
and part of the reason
the book took so
long, the research.
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
How long did it take?
ANJALI KUMAR: I worked on it--
I probably researched--
I started it when
Zia was about one.
She's turning nine in February.
I mean, probably like
six, seven years.
I mean, I've researched
and writing--
not constantly
obviously, but yeah.
Over the course of six
years, six, seven years.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Yeah.
It's a full-time thing.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah, yeah.
And so basically, you lie
on the ground, and this guy,
he's like a 65,
70-year old Indian man
who is not my husband.
He lies on top of you.
There's a sheet between you
so it's weirdly not sexual.
I mean, not for me at least.
So he lies on top of
you, and then he chants.
I can't believe I'm telling
this story at Google.
He chants into
your chakra points.
So if you know where
your chakras are,
you can use your imagination
of what that entails.
But he sounds into your head,
and then like your throat, then
your boobs.
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
All the way down.
ANJALI KUMAR: All the way down.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Got it.
ANJALI KUMAR: He goes
all the way down,
and it was super bizarre,
I mean, as you can imagine.
So he's doing this, and it
goes on for like 45 minutes.
It's a really--
yeah, like you're
committed to this experience.
And then it's a group
activity because there's
people who are not
all doing it with him,
but they're all sitting around
you as this is happening.
So I mean, it's just-- it was--
that just wrote itself.
Like I don't know how you
don't write about that
and share that experience
with people if you
have experienced it yourself.
But it was crazy.
But it was also oddly relaxing.
It was like having noise
canceling headphones on
or being surrounded by like bees
but they're not stinging you,
like just the humming.
I know it sounds strange.
It was actually
kind of delightful.
I haven't gone
back, but I probably
should because it was--
there were people
who really enjoyed it
much more than I did.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: You'll
have to give me his number.
ANJALI KUMAR: I will.
He's on Facebook.
He follows me on Facebook.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Awesome.
So speaking of group
activities, one
of the things you talk about
is going to this Wiccan potluck
dinner.
Can you tell us a
little bit about that?
Because I found those--
so when I think about
Wicca, I'm kind of like,
these are witches, and
you know, I don't really
know what that means and
it sounds a little dark.
But that chapter was
super lighthearted
and the women seemed
really lovely.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
Everybody was amazing.
That was actually
one of the chapters
that I think really
challenged my own, I guess,
unconscious bias
against witches.
I didn't know I had it,
but it was the one thing--
I know.
I'm sorry if anyone
in here is a Wiccan.
Like I'm fully converted,
like I'm in it.
I really respect what you do.
That was the one thing
that my editor actually
encouraged me to do.
So everything else was
basically researched and planned
of what I was doing or I had
already done the research,
and my editor was
like, you know, the gap
that you have in this is Wicca.
And I was like, why?
Like I had this really
childlike preconception
of what it would
mean to be a Wiccan.
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
Black pointy hats?
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah,
black pointy hats.
You know, my kid
watches Disney movies.
Like that's what I was
picturing, which is so--
you know, it's such
an unconscious bias.
I didn't even realize that I
had this bias against witches.
But I was like, I
don't want to do that.
It's kind of scary.
Like, I don't want to do that.
And then she kind of
kept encouraging me.
She was like, I feel
like that's the one thing
that people do when
they first step out
of traditional religion, that
a lot of people explore that.
And I was like, all right, fine.
So I started researching it.
And as I researched
more and more,
I was like, this is
actually super interesting,
because there's no
like rulebook, right?
Like it really is a
choose what you want--
CRISTIN FRODELLA: A la carte.
ANJALI KUMAR:
--religion and practice.
Yeah, in a way that I
think so much of us who
don't ascribe to a specific
religion or religious tradition
but still want to find
something in some meaning
would actually be like,
oh yeah, that makes sense.
Like I believe in eating
seasonally or whatever.
You know, like I respect nature.
Like I do a lot of the things
that are core principles.
I believe in being
good to people
and hoping that that comes back
to me and that kind of thing.
And so I went to a potluck.
It was a Thanksgiving
potluck for--
but not related to
American Thanksgiving.
It was, I guess,
Wicca Thanksgiving.
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
Is there a Wicca--
when is Wicca Thanksgiving?
ANJALI KUMAR: It was right
around my daughter's homecoming
time, so like it was
probably, I think,
October, September, October.
I think it's done by
the lunar calendar.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Oh, yeah.
It must be harvest.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
It's like harvest, exactly.
And it was at the LGBT
Center in Manhattan,
and it was really wonderful.
Like after I got over the sort
of initial awkwardness of just
dining with strangers, it was
such a wonderful, warm group
of people.
And it was really
just people, again,
searching like the
rest of us, just trying
to find a community,
trying to find connection.
A lot of people
were new to the city
and they were just
looking for somebody else
to have that kind
of moment with,
and it was a really
lovely dinner.
And these witches could cook.
It was good food.
My contributions
were lackluster,
but theirs were quite delicious.
It was a really special evening.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: So was there
any time during this, I guess,
journey where your
curiosity was really
piqued about a
particular religion,
where you were saying
like, maybe I'll
actually go in that direction?
ANJALI KUMAR: You
know, I didn't really
do traditional religious stuff.
So I mean, Wicca was probably
the most traditional religion
that I explored--
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
Spiritualities.
ANJALI KUMAR: --which
kind of gives you an idea.
Yeah.
So the meditation was
really powerful for me.
I think that's something
that I had started doing when
I worked at Google, in fact.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: The
TM or the vipassana?
ANJALI KUMAR: The
TM, the TM part.
And that's a practice
that's really stuck with me
and that's become almost
like mental hygiene for me,
like a daily flossing.
Like I just do it
because it feels good.
And it's not like your
teeth will fall out
if you don't floss one day, but
you kind of feel icky all day.
It's like that's what I
feel like about meditation.
It's like, if I don't meditate--
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Do you do 10
minutes in the morning and 10
minutes at night?
ANJALI KUMAR: I do 20
minutes in the morning.
I used to be able to do 20
minutes in the afternoon
when I worked here
because they had
things like the mother's room.
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
Because Google.
ANJALI KUMAR: And
because Google, I know.
But then don't
leave Google ever.
You can never do
that kind of stuff
when you leave this place.
There is no meditation
room at other start-ups,
like they don't have the space.
So that practice fell by the
wayside when I left Google.
But when I was here,
it was something
that I did twice a day and
was pretty committed to it.
So that's a practice
that's really stuck for me.
And in terms of the
other things, not really.
Like none of them are
things that I've been like,
oh, I want to go back
to that again and again
and I think this is my thing.
But I think I've gotten
to be OK with that.
I sort of got to the end
of the journey, at least
for the narrative of
this story, and got
comfortable with just sort
of stopping for a minute.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: When was that?
What happened?
What was the turning point?
ANJALI KUMAR: You know,
I did the vipassana.
I went on the silent
meditation retreat,
and I think just being
still for that long
and shutting up for a while
was really good for me,
and it got me out of my
head and it got me out
of this sort of frantic
search, and just being like,
you know, you probably know the
answers to a lot of the things,
at least what's true for
you, if you just quiet
down a little bit and
stop for a minute,
and so that's what
I ultimately did.
I sort of stopped
the frantic search.
It felt like a
nice, natural ending
to the story for
this particular book.
And I don't have that same kind
of urgency around answering
these questions, but
I still-- you know,
people ask me to do stuff all
the time, and I'm like, yeah.
Let's go do that.
I think the curiosity
and the search of it
is still fun for me so
I, every so often, will
go do like [INAUDIBLE].
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Yeah.
I'm pretty sure if you asked any
of the people in this audience
if they wanted to come with you,
including me, yes, they would.
So I have to ask,
what about Zia?
Like what was the
end result for her?
She must have seen
you doing this.
She knew you published the book.
Like how did this
impact her life?
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
So she was really little when I
was doing most of the research,
and so I think she just
thinks I'm sort of kooky
and like always
off doing things.
It was concerning when she would
tell her teachers about where
I was, because you can imagine
in a Manhattan private school,
they're like, oh, we heard you
weren't talking for a few days,
and is everything OK?
And I was like, no.
I was at a retreat.
You know, like her kindergarten
teachers were super concerned
when I came back from
that silent retreat
because they were just
given a bit of information.
But I think what's been
the most interesting thing,
for the questions, she
does ask me questions
that are themed to
the book, and we just
have conversations about it.
I'm like, what do you
think the answer is?
Like, I don't know what
happens when you die.
What do you think?
And she actually weirdly
has a very easy relationship
with the idea of death.
Like that's something
that, since she was little,
I had told her--
actually when Dan
Fredinburg died,
I had told her that
when people die,
that they become
stars in the sky.
My husband and I
had told her this
because she had come across
a picture of his mother
who had passed away
when he was quite young.
And I don't know
why we said that,
but that's what we
kind of turned to.
We were like, yeah,
they become stars.
She was like three.
And so when Dan passed away
and she heard me on the phone
talking to somebody
and getting the news,
she was like, what happened?
And I said, well a good
friend of our friends
died in an earthquake.
And she sort of pauses,
and she's like, oh.
You mean he became
a star in the sky?
And I was like, oh.
Yeah.
I think he did.
You know, it was just a really--
like maybe I'm not
screwing this up so badly.
But it was a really
beautiful moment.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Yeah.
You also described to me
another beautiful moment
about the librarian in
your daughter's school
and I wondered if you
would tell all these--
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
It's not really related
to the spirituality piece,
but I think just the idea of
all these conversations we're
having in a place like Google
or just across corporate America
or Hollywood or anywhere around
diversity and inclusiveness.
And one of the things
I did not expect
was how much having that book
on a shelf would mean to me.
And so the story we were talking
about, when my book came out,
soon after, my daughter's
school librarian sent me a text.
She sent me a picture of the
book in the school library,
and she was like, we just
got a copy of your book in.
The next time you're in,
could you sign it for us?
And I just started crying.
And I was so
surprised, like this
is the most impactful thing.
Like I had done a TED
Talk, and I was like,
this is the moment
where I was like,
I can't believe that my little
kid will walk into a school
library, to her school library,
and see a story that literally
reflects her, reflects her
story in some way back to her.
I get like a little choked
up thinking about it.
And it meant so much to
me because growing up
in this country in the
time that I grew up,
I did not have that
expectation, and I didn't even
know it was an option.
Like I didn't know I was
being cut out of a narrative
or that my narrative didn't
exist on the library shelves
or in Hollywood
or anything else.
It was just like, oh,
I'm a recent immigrant
to this country, why
would my story be told?
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Nobody
would tell your story.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah,
like, you know, I
had to watch Bollywood films.
And that's definitely not
my narrative, but you know,
that's what I would watch to
see somebody who looked like me
and definitely can dance
like me on the screen.
But it wasn't something
I had an expectation of.
And to know that
she and her friends
would have that experience
was so, so moving
and meaningful to me in a
way that I wasn't expecting.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Yeah.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: So what now?
So what are you doing now?
ANJALI KUMAR: Oh gosh, the
million dollar question.
I'm trying to come
back to Google.
I've decided that I can just
hide out in the hallways
and none of you
would even notice.
Like I could just
stay here forever.
No, I'm kidding.
The book came out a bit
ago, a few months ago,
and so there's been some
great, exciting interest
around turning it into
television in some way, which
it would be--
I mean, talk about like
seeing yourself onscreen.
Not that I would be in it, but
that other people would be--
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
Who would play you?
ANJALI KUMAR: Ooh.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Who do
you think would play you?
ANJALI KUMAR: Julia Roberts.
No, I'm totally kidding.
I don't know.
I like the idea
of Archie Panjabi.
Do you guys remember her
from "Bend It Like Beckham?"
She played by the sister
in "Bend It Like Beckham."
She's super funny and she
was like quick and funny.
I really liked her.
So yeah, maybe her.
And then I told my husband
that Dev Patel should play him.
I'm just saying.
And he started getting
annoyed with me,
because I kept saying like,
did you see him in "GQ?"
Like he's suddenly called
the Slumdog Millionaire.
Like this guy got super cute.
He should play you.
And he's like,
you've got to stop.
So yeah.
It was only funny
to me apparently.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: I hit
on him in a gym once.
ANJALI KUMAR: You did?
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Yeah.
It was great.
ANJALI KUMAR: We'll talk
about that in the after show.
That's amazing.
Yeah, so there's some
talk of that which would
be really, really exciting.
I'm thinking about if I
would write another book.
I don't know.
I'm doing some writing,
like sort of my first time
doing different things.
I was just a clown in
the Macy's Day Parade.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Oh, you were?
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah, super fun.
There's definitely
an article there.
I highly recommend all of
you to do that if you ever
have the opportunity.
You can volunteer to be a clown
in the Macy's Thanksgiving Day
Parade.
Didn't know that was a thing.
Super fun, totally crazy.
So there's things like
that and I'm exploring.
And then I don't know.
We'll see.
I'm excited.
Stay tuned.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: All right.
Cool, cool.
Well, before we open
it up to questions,
I guess I would say,
what advice do you have
for fellow seekers like me?
ANJALI KUMAR: I definitely
don't have answers,
and I really do think
it is about ultimately
getting still and knowing that
you have them inside of you.
Like that whoever is
telling you that they know,
they know for them but they
don't necessarily know for you.
That's my gut.
CRISTIN FRODELLA:
That's good advice.
All right.
Thank you.
ANJALI KUMAR: Thank you.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Will
take some questions
from folks in the audience?
ANJALI KUMAR: Yes, please.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Anybody
have any questions?
ANJALI KUMAR: Not all at once.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ANJALI KUMAR: Hi.
I'm [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you so much.
I think it's really interesting,
what you spoke about.
I definitely would
read the book.
But what I'm finding
it difficult to
is tying all this together.
And if you had to
say something, like
what should a reader
take away from this book?
Like is there a
underlying thing.
Like, hey, I did this,
this, this, this,
and this is what
I would conclude
or this is what I would say.
I'm just trying to
figure that out.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
Thank you for your question.
I think the conclusion is really
a bit of a non-conclusion.
It was sort of like, this
is an ongoing journey.
This is something that--
it was very naive of me
to think that I can
answer within the pages
of a 250-page book.
Because if that was
possible, somebody
would have done it already.
And it was really that
I'll be searching probably
for the rest of my life
and that I'm OK with that.
And then the story that I
told earlier about John of God
and about the letters
that I had received,
that, for me, was
really a conclusion too.
It was just that we're all
seeking the same things.
And so the health, happiness,
and love part of that
gave me a lot of
comfort that ultimately,
everyone that I know really
wants the same things.
And if I can focus on that
and on the things that bind
us together as opposed to the
things that drive us apart,
especially in times like this,
that I might be on the path
to something.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANJALI KUMAR: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Anjali.
Thanks for coming.
ANJALI KUMAR: Hi, Erica.
Thanks for being here.
AUDIENCE: So the tech industry
is facing some really massive
questions around responsibility,
accountability in analog parts
of society and the way we've--
yeah, in so many ways, right?
Sundar was in
Congress yesterday.
You also mentioned it was
interesting thinking about
how, when you
started this journey,
you were a little bit
quiet about it at Google.
And so the third part
of this is Jack Dorsey
posted this tweet
storm a few days ago.
He did a 10-day silent
meditation retreat in Myanmar.
What do you think the
space is or the role
is for spirituality in tech?
Why is it not talked about?
And at the executive
level, do you
think it's an important
character trait for a leader?
ANJALI KUMAR: That's such
a great question, which
I know is not the
response you're
supposed to give to a
question, but it really
is a great question.
Why is it not talked about?
Do you guys watch
"Silicon Valley?"
I mean, I suppose you
live "Silicon Valley"
so you don't need to watch it.
So I had missed seasons
of it, and there's
like season 5 or something
on United Flights,
and I was watching like one
episode, which you can catch up
on pretty quickly, but like, you
can figure out what's going on.
And it was an episode about
one of the developers who
was going to come onto the
plot for the new internet
where they find out
that he's Christian.
So it's like he's going to
start a gay dating website,
and it's like, that's cool.
That's great.
[INAUDIBLE] knew that.
And then it's like, wait.
He's Christian?
They're like,
don't tell anybody.
And it becomes this big thing.
And I thought it
was so fascinating.
So like, that's what
it's like, right?
It's like the last taboo.
We talk about everything now.
Nothing's off the table.
But for some reason,
the thing that arguably
is one of the most
important things,
like what do you believe about
the things that really matter,
that really drive
your every day,
and we can't have
those conversations.
And I don't know why that is.
I was embarrassed to talk
about it because I really
thought everyone would
think I was nuts,
and I'm sure people did.
I remember a conversation at one
of the Women at Google events.
I had just come back
from Brazil and I
was talking to a very senior
salesperson at Google.
And I was telling her, and you
could see her backing away.
She was kind of like, all
right, like this woman's crazy.
And it was just such an
interesting experience
because I'm not this like
deeply religious person.
But the fact that
I even have to say
that by way of contextualizing,
like don't worry,
I'm not religious,
like I'm just a seeker
and I'm doing a lot
of this for fun,
and I have to make people
comfortable with that, I think,
is really interesting.
But the thing that I've
also found interesting
is that since I've written
this book, people come up to me
and they spill forth
their religious views
or their spiritual views or
their religious upbringings
like a confessional to me now.
So I know all kinds
of stuff about people.
People in tech, not in tech,
like all over the planet.
And that's been really
interesting to me.
So to me, there seems
to be a clear desire
to talk about these things
because people really
do want to get to the
stuff that matters.
And I think until we all start
talking about this stuff,
nothing's going to change.
So is it important for
our senior leadership
in a place like Google
to talk about that stuff?
I don't know.
I don't want to impose on
Sundar that he should be telling
everybody if he's Hindu
and if he's practicing
and if he goes to temple
and if he believes in God.
Like it maybe doesn't matter.
But I think if that is
something that drives him
and it's a belief
system that informs
how he leads his company,
I think that's interesting.
I would want to know that
just out of curiosity.
I think it'd be interesting.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Anjali.
Thank you for coming.
So I, myself, am a
vipassana meditater
and I did the 10-day
course and everything.
But I'm new to
New York, and I've
found it to be extremely
difficult in New York
to find like 20 minutes
just to like calm down.
So do you have any advice or
tips on how to meditate daily?
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
You need to get access to
the mother's room at Google,
and then go in there.
I'm sort of kidding,
but it's sort of true.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: We actually
have focus rooms now.
ANJALI KUMAR: You
have focus rooms?
Ooh.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Yes.
We have focus rooms where you're
not supposed to do anything
except for sit and think.
ANJALI KUMAR: Wow.
I really want to come back.
Don't ever leave.
That is the secret.
Joking aside, I think it's
being really intentional
about carving out the time
and doing it no matter what.
And I think if you start--
when I did that first TM class,
I remember they said you
had to do it for two months,
I think, where they're
like, try to not
break the habit or the
streak for two months,
and then it just
became a thing I did.
Where now, I'm not
a morning person,
and I will wake
up early to do it.
So if you can, I would start
by just waking up early,
like if it's 20 minutes,
10 minutes, whatever
your practice is.
And then if you're trying to
find space during the day,
if you can block off a
meeting, I would do that.
And I think in a
place like Google,
people respect it actually.
It's not necessarily
true of other workplaces.
I can tell you that,
because they'll be like,
we've got a meeting.
This is the only other
time everyone can meet
and they just schedule over it.
But I feel like here, you could
actually carve that space.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Have you
done "Search Inside Yourself?
AUDIENCE: No.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: So there
is a course here called
"Search Inside Yourself," which
is essentially a meditation
course started by an ex-Googler
who's an incredible guy, Meng.
Anyway, so "Search Inside
Yourself" is a course here.
And at the end of it, you get
paired up with a fellow SIY
alumni, and the goal is
essentially you have meetings
together so that you can carve
out the time to meditate.
And if you write to that list,
which is SIY dash alumni--
I don't know actually if
you'll be able to access it,
but there are tons
of people who I'm
sure would love to
set up time with you.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
Hi.
So I feel like
maybe the questions
that you started with in this
book and the questions that
kind of started this talk
are generally like universal
among people, and I think
that everyone kind of wonders
about a lot of these things.
Thinking about like
myself personally,
I think my instincts, or like
whatever my first movement here
would be to think
about exploring
the more major religions and
the more mainstream religions.
And I think that a lot
of the stuff you explored
would kind of be a
secondary thought.
Can you talk a little bit
more about your decision
to kind of go that route instead
of the more mainstream religion
route?
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
It was really because
I'm not a theologian
and I didn't feel
drawn to any of them,
so I didn't feel like I
could do an adequate job
of like exploring Christianity
and then a little bit
of Judaism and then Islam.
It's like, how do you do
that in a meaningful way
with a full-time
job with a new kid?
And I didn't feel
drawn to any of them,
because I don't think this
project was necessarily
a rejection of the
religion I was raised with.
If you asked me now,
what religion are you?
I'd probably still answer Jain.
I'm Jainish.
Like people are
Jewish, I'm Jainish.
You know, that's
still directionally
what I feel makes sense for me
because it's so cultural to me.
So I think because I tied
religion and culture so much
together, it would be like
searching for a new culture,
and that wasn't
really the project.
But a lot of people have
asked me that question.
Yeah, it wasn't something that
felt like the right direction.
And so I went in this
kind of other direction.
But everything
that I searched for
and all the
experiences that I did
were very much authentically
what I felt curious about.
And so it wasn't like, oh,
what will make a funny chapter.
It was like, no.
I kind of want to
go to Burning Man
and I think I want to
do a silent meditation.
Like it was things that
I actually wanted to try.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
a follow-up question?
ANJALI KUMAR: Please, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you
talk a little bit more
about the title of
the book, because I
feel like this may be--
like, God is something
that I associate maybe more
with mainstream religions than
with other spiritual practices,
and I'd be interested to
hear kind of your thoughts
about the connection
between those and God.
ANJALI KUMAR: Sure.
So the original
title of the book
that I sold the proposal on was
actually "From Google to God."
And I loved it and I thought
it was really a funny title,
and then my editor, halfway
through my writing process,
was like, you've got
to change the title
because it sounds like you
left Google to become a priest.
And I was like, aw.
That's true and that's not
what happens in this book.
But the idea of it
just being a search,
I wanted some reference
to the tech kind
of piece of it and the fact that
tech played such a large part
certainly in my personal journey
in just of life and my career,
but then also in how I was
accessing a lot of these things
because so much of it started
with an internet search.
You know, that was
part of the narrative.
The stalking
reference, you know,
it's a bit of a provocative
sort of word to use.
But it's certainly like
a Facebook stalking
kind of reference of like--
but again, tongue in cheek.
So there was a lot of
thought put into the title,
and I think it can be
confusing to people.
There's definitely
Amazon reviewers
who do not like my
book because they're
like, that's not the answer
and Christianity is the answer,
whatever.
There's a couple of very
angry people on Amazon.
And I was like, well, then
it's not for you and I get it.
But it was meant to be a
bit tongue in cheek too.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANJALI KUMAR: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: My first question
was the same as his actually.
My next question is, was
anybody actually healed,
like that you took to
the Brazilian healer guy,
like the people's
photos and stuff?
ANJALI KUMAR: Oh, the follow-up.
AUDIENCE: Like did
anybody ever actually--
ANJALI KUMAR: Of the photos--
so I don't think
anyone I brought
photos of was struggling
with a real medical condition
of the batch that I had.
But that said, in follow-ups--
so John of God also makes a
trip to like Omega Institute
in upstate New York.
And so I had gone last year
before my book came out.
I drove up there because he was
coming, and I was kind of like,
I feel like I should show a
picture of my book cover to him
and have him scan
that and heal it.
I thought it'd be kind of like
a nice tying up for myself.
I don't know if he did it, but
I left a picture of the book
cover in his basket,
and I did bring
a photograph of a friend who
was just diagnosed with breast
cancer, and she is cancer free.
I don't think that did it.
I mean, she also had
medical treatment.
But I don't know.
If it gives somebody a little
bit of hope, I think that's OK.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Anjali.
Thank you for coming.
I really enjoyed that,
especially because last night,
I had like my monthly
existential crisis
reflecting on like
these sorts of ideas.
And one of the thoughts
that came was--
and this is actually a follow-up
from a podcast I was listening
to earlier this week--
was that this sort of
rationalist mindset, the very
scientific driven
mindset is fairly modern.
Like it's a byproduct of the
post-industrial revolution
movements.
And it's sort of like when
you have that mindset where
you want to critically analyze,
OK, why is this happening,
I found that, even
doing meditation,
my first thought
after is like, OK.
I felt something, but
like why did I feel that?
It has to be some like
neurological process
that's causing this.
Clearly, there has to be a
rational explanation for that.
So when you're
doing all of these
like very unorthodox
things, did you
find that you needed to suspend
that sort of mindset of like,
OK.
There has to be a
clearly rational way
to explain why
this is happening.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah, 100%.
So when you read my
book, the narrative
really plays out that way.
There's like this a
very lawyerly part
of me that does the research
and will talk about oxytocin
release during a hug and
like what that might mean,
and that's why hugging
Amma could be effective,
because of that.
But then the other side
is kind of like, well
what's the feeling?
Like she smelled really nice.
Like it was a little sweaty, a
little uncomfortable, but like
it was also nice.
And that juxtaposition,
I mean, it was constant.
Like there was a constant
dialogue in my head.
It continues to be just the way
I work and navigate the world,
but that was very,
very hard for me
and I would keep
flipping back and forth.
And I do address it
a lot in the book
because I think so many of us
are in the same position where
it's like we're raised to
think a very specific way,
and we're educated
and overeducated
and sort of repeating
things again
and again to become
experts at something.
And then here's this
whole set of questions
that are truly not Googleable.
You will not find a
satisfactory answer.
You will find people purporting
to know the answers on Google
to all these questions.
I would challenge
that maybe there are
incorrect answers on Google.
You need to tweak the algorithm
on these particular things,
but there are just things
that are unknowable.
And so if you start--
I don't know how you
reconcile those things,
but I kind of flip
back and forth too.
But then ultimately,
it was like,
I've just got to
suspend disbelief.
Like I can't try to
explain these things,
otherwise, I'll just
be stuck in a loop.
AUDIENCE: Just as
a small follow-up,
when you were actually
having these experiences,
did you just like push aside any
of the thoughts that are like,
OK, why is this happening?
ANJALI KUMAR: No.
I think I did it
really unsuccessfully.
There were moments that I would,
like the tantric sound healing
being a perfect example.
There are moments where I
was like, this is so weird.
And like my head
was like, oh my god.
I cannot believe--
I should not be doing this.
My parents, like what
would they think?
Like they're going
to hear about this.
I'm going to write.
I can't write about-- like
I was going on and on.
I was like, this is bananas.
I am married.
Like what am I doing?
You know, it was just like
a loop, a loop, a loop.
And then there are moments
where I was kind of like,
all right, just like relax.
Just breathe into it,
and I was like, oh.
It's kind of nice.
Like this is bizarre,
but also kind
of not altogether unpleasant.
And then I'd be like, oh my god.
I can't believe this man
is lying on top of me.
This is very awkward.
And so it would just be
like a constant thing.
And that, for me, is
also my meditation cycle,
is like the monkey mind of the
loop of like, what's going on?
I have to make dinner.
I have to go do this thing.
I forgot to pick up
the dry cleaning.
Blah, blah, blah.
And then I'm like, oh.
I'm suppose to be meditating.
I'm like, mantra,
mantra, mantra, mantra.
I'm like ah.
And I'm like, crap,
so I fall asleep.
And I just keep going
and it's like constant.
And I feel like that's
the very human journey.
I don't live in
the woods, right?
Like I don't live on
a meditation farm.
I live in New York City.
I live downtown.
I take the subway.
I walk everywhere.
Like it is hectic and I think
that's just part of our life,
but if you can push that reset
button every day in some way.
And the fact that you're just
asking the questions I think
is great.
AUDIENCE: Well thank you.
Appreciate it.
ANJALI KUMAR: Going
back this way.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Nice to see you.
Thank you for coming in.
How did you know--
it sounds like
you got to a point
where you felt at peace,
that you had searched enough.
You didn't find specific answers
and you were OK with that.
Can you describe that?
Because when you're just
talking about the constant loop
and it's really hard
to break that cycle,
how did you feel
fulfilled on this journey
and what was that
moment like for you?
ANJALI KUMAR:
There were a couple
of things that drove that.
I think one was definitely
the silent meditation
experience of just being
still for that long.
I didn't do a full 10 days.
I tell that story
of why in the book,
but I did a five-day retreat.
And by the end, I was like, I
think I'm good for a minute.
Like I feel like just
stopping and I just
need to sit with what
I've already researched
and sort of be in that, and
feel like I have enough data
to inform something
that felt right.
And then also, truthfully,
it was partially
because I was on deadline.
I was like, I can't
keep searching
and I've got to
turn this book in,
and I have to be OK with
not having a conclusion
because I'm not going to in
time for this book to come out.
And so either I can
spend the rest of my life
writing this book and it'll
be written and published
posthumously, or I can
try to wrap this up and be
OK with the knowledge
that I will never know
the answer to these questions.
And that's where
I chose to land.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Thank you.
One more question.
It sounds like the
impetus of this search
was more about your
daughter and the questions
she might have as
she grows older.
When did you decide,
hey, this is a book,
and I should probably put
this out there for more people
to absorb?
ANJALI KUMAR: Ooh.
That's a good question.
There was a moment where
it was going to be a film,
and then I realized I did
not want to be in a film,
and so that was pushed aside.
But I felt like
there was something
I wanted to do with it because
it was fun and anyone I would
tell the stories to would be
like, you have to write this
down.
These are such funny
stories or they're
really interesting or whatever,
depending on what story it was.
So I started taking better
notes as I would do things.
And then I met an
agent a few years ago,
and he was like, you've
got to write this.
Like, this is a book
I know I can sell it.
And that's what
ended up happening.
So I never set out
to write a book.
It just sort of--
and it sounds like such
a jerky thing to be like,
it just sort of happened, but
that's kind of what happened.
It felt like, you know,
Jesus took the wheel.
No, I'm just joking.
That's inappropriate, but I just
feel like it just sort of just
played out the way it
was meant to I think.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
How forthcoming were you when
you went and traveled around
and met with
different-- like when
you went to the Wiccan potluck.
Did they ask you
why you were there?
Did you tell them?
And if so, what
was the response?
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
I was incredibly forthcoming.
I am a lawyer.
I do not want to
get sued by anybody.
I wasn't trying to dupe anybody.
I was very, very clear that--
once I decided to
turn it into a book,
I was very clear that
I was writing a book.
And for anybody that
was prior chapters,
I reached out to
people to make sure
that they were OK with
what I was writing,
because everything
in the book was true.
And so any one that,
certainly if I named them,
I gave everyone the opportunity
to change their name
or to read what I was writing
because I didn't want anyone
to feel made fun of
or kind of sideswiped
from what I was writing,
because it was not
meant to be like a take down of
all these different practices,
so I was very, very
forthcoming when I did it.
Thank you from the legal
team of Google for asking.
AUDIENCE: Were there
any ways in which
you feel like your
life has been changed
in either positive
or negative ways
that you were not expecting
after this experience?
ANJALI KUMAR: From
the research or just
from the whole experience?
AUDIENCE: The research,
writing, anything.
Yeah.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
It's opened up in
ways that I wouldn't
have expected for sure.
I think just what it did was--
one of the habits.
I think I learned
working at Google
actually was to be
ready for anything
and to really put myself into
uncomfortable situations.
Like again, as a lawyer, you're
trained to know something,
to go really deep on that
issue, to really be the expert.
And working at Google
in the years that I did,
that was not going
to be the situation.
It was like, here's
a new product.
We're launching
this other thing,
and you just had to
go figure it out.
And working that
muscle here I think
led to me being
really comfortable
going into these very
uncomfortable situations
for the research for
this book, and has
become a theme of both my
career and my personal life
since then, where it's
been like it's just
opened up all these things.
Because something like
becoming a clown in the Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade,
like that is not something
I would ever have
thought I would do.
And I went and I had so
much fun and it was so goofy
and it was such a
delightful thing to do,
and I think it's because
I worked at Google
and then did something like this
that I'm willing to put myself
out there and sort of suck
the marrow out of life
while I'm here.
And I think that's
definitely what
this has taught me, for sure.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: Thank
you, Anjali, for coming.
And I think if we've
learned anything,
it's that in addition to
wanting love and health
and what was the other?
ANJALI KUMAR: Happiness.
CRISTIN FRODELLA: And happiness.
I think also,
everybody kind of wants
to know what's it all about.
So thanks for bringing us
together to talk about that.
And if you haven't read the
book yet, I highly recommend it.
It's so much fun.
It's such a fun journey.
At the back of the
room, pick up a copy.
And it's nice to see you all.
ANJALI KUMAR: Thank
you all for being here.
Thank you so much [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]